die steinernen bruders von bamian
1500 jahre haben die riesenstatue nahezu
unversehrt überstanden bis die taliban
das weltkulturerbe 2001 zerstörten die
botschaft ihres damaligen führers mullah
omar warum es verständlich keine kultur
außer der islamischen ist in afghanistan
geduldet wie der aufbauhilfe leistet
seit 2004 der bayerische restaurator
berg braxenthaler doch mit der
machtergreifung droht sich nun das
trauma der zerstörung zu wiederholen
die taliban erst mal versucht die
hooters zu zerstören indem sie granaten
fliegerbomben alles möglich explosiven
material panzerminen unter den wird das
aufgehäuft haben versucht das springen
das war relativ dilettantische versuch
hat auch nicht so funktioniert hat in
der teilweise beschädigt und die haben
dann erst was man die leute dann erzählt
haben wohl sprengmeister aus pakistan
geholt dienen dann gezeigt wie man sowas
fachgerecht ab sprengt das wasser ein
wort in den mund stopft und dann haben
sich die beiden das entsprechend dann
zerstört die zusage der taliban künftig
auch vor islamische kunst vor
grabräubern zu schützen scheint in
bamian nicht viel wert zu sein erster
depots wurden geplündert fundstücke zum
verkauf angeboten mit dem machtwechsel
sind auch die helfer vor ort bedroht
unter ihnen viele angehörige der
verfolgten volksgruppe der schiitischen
hazara
wir hatten ja zum teil bis zu 50
mitarbeiter ausbauen beschäftigt gerade
leute die 2004 bis 2017 kontinuierlich
für uns gearbeitet haben die haben
natürlich jetzt große sorge dass sie
wirklich von den taliban
übel misshandelt werden die sind alle
noch am ort verstecken sich und wir
haben wirklich sorge um ihr leben und
das ihrer familie auch deren hoffnungen
liegen nun auf dem nachbarland iran das
versprochen hat den hazara visa
auszustellen dank deutsch-japanischer
vermittlung
bruchstückhafte restaurierung stadt
rekonstruktion so lautete der plan
deutsche archäologen für die buddhas von
bamiyan bis die arbeiten 2017 durch
bürokratische hürden und
finanzierungsprobleme ins stocken
gerieten
die kuratorin susanne ahnen hat
jahrelang vorislamische kulturgüter
geborgen archiviert und sogar auf
ausstellungs reisen in den westen
geschickt
auch grabungsarbeiten an der
buddhistischen tempel anlage mesz 1 nach
hat sie begleitet
große darunter liegende kupfervorkommen
deren schürfrechte chinesischen bergbau
unternehmen gehören dürften unter den
taliban neue begehrlichkeiten wecken
also man noch den afghanen nicht
verwehren können ihre ihre bodenschätze
zu veräußern ihre bodenschätze abzubauen
es handelt sich hier um eine wirklich
eine riesengroße kupfermine die
natürlich auch arbeitsplätze und geld
ins land bringt und da muss man dann
schon so ein bisschen abhängen und so
ein bisschen differenzieren das glück
ist eben das ist nun zehn jahre gab um
diese dokumentation zu machen und nicht
wie erst vorgesehen drei jahre dann das
ist ja auch schon ein großes glück die
dortigen buddhistischen funde aus messel
sind inzwischen im nationalmuseum in
kabul ausgestellt für wie lange noch
entscheiden nunmehr die taliban ich kann
mir schon vorstellen dass sie auch
verstanden haben dass auch damit geld zu
verdienen ist es gibt leider gehören die
die sachen werden in der welt gezeigt
und ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass das
auch in das denken der köpfe dieser
menschen rein geht dass das ein
positiver botschafter sein kann und dass
sie mit einem anderen verhalten die
internationale gemeinschaft sehr
verärgern werden weil wir reden ja hier
von dem weltkulturerbe und
weltkulturerbe ist ja doch so dass es
uns allen in irgendeiner form naja
gehört
diese königliche palast anlage aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert wurde im
afghanischen bürgerkrieg schwer
beschädigt die aga khan stiftung hat sie
in rekordzeit wieder aufgebaut sinnbild
einer neuen afghanischen normalität die
bereits wieder vergangenheit ist
[Musik]
einer der architekten ist sie kann da
sehr hart groß neffe des letzten
afghanische könig amanullah
in 20 jahren wieder aufbauarbeit hat er
die taliban auch als selektive kultur
bewahrer erlebt wie etwa im falle dieses
palast im herzen kabuls der mithilfe der
gerda henkel stiftung restauriert wurde
[Musik]
die haben es in ihrer
schreckensherrschaft nicht angerührt für
die war das ein wunderschönes gebäude
was sie nicht zerstören wollten und
nicht zerstört haben und ich hoffe dass
es dieses mal auch so ist es gibt nichts
in diesem gebäude fast zerstörungs wert
wäre
viele afghanen wurden mit ausländischer
hilfe zu archäologinnen kuratorinnen
oder architekt innen ausgebildet dass
die taliban sie weiter beschäftigen gilt
als unwahrscheinlich
wie aber soll sich der westen angesichts
der rückschritte in menschen und frauen
rechtsfragen verhalten man muss es
anpacken um
den gemäßigten zu helfen und das ganze
zu leiten das wäre schon denke ich eine
hauptaufgabe die man die der westen
jetzt hat
um afghanistan oder alte kultur alte
alles was afghanistan betrifft das ist
ja ein land mit über
3000 jahre alte kultur die da existiert
und dass man das nicht alles zerstört
nicht alles komplett verliert denke dass
jetzt die zeit da ist eine große chance
da ist dass man mit denen reden kann und
reden muss
bürgerkrieg migration und hungersnöte
dürften den druck auf afghanistans
vorislamische kulturgüter erhöhen wenn
der westen das welterbe von bamyan
retten will muss er notgedrungen mit den
taliban ins gespräch kommen